qué mensaje envía el hecho de que
bolsonaro haya usado este acto para
impulsar su campaña cuando se supone que
es un festivo o un feriado no partidista
buenas noches de san andreas buenas
noches a todos los televidentes bueno lo
principal que hemos tenido en esta
jornada del 7 de septiembre ha sido la
demostración de fuerza del presidente
airport sonar en todas las encuestas que
hemos tenido hasta el día de hoy estamos
a menos de 30 días de la realización de
las elecciones le muestran casi 12
puntos por detrás del ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva el presidente se
emocionaron más bien de apropiarse de
los símbolos patrios en la visión de los
miles de seguidores que va acumulando ha
rescatado estos símbolos que durante los
14 años en que ha gobernado la izquierda
de brasil los ha abandonado
completamente había un clima de mucha
atención en la noche que anticipó
justamente los eventos del 7 de
septiembre porque varias autoridades los
partidos de oposición los adversarios
los enemigos de bolsonaro
veían mucha violencia muchos ataques y
lo que nosotros hemos tenido ha sido una
jornada muy pacífica y sorprendente
desde el punto de vista de la cantidad
de gente que ha arrastrado el presidente
a las calles hay que puntuar andrés que
el 7 de septiembre ha sido siempre una
especie de monopolio de los movimientos
sociales y los partidos de izquierda que
aprovechaban esta fecha justamente para
hacer lo que hoy acusan al presidente de
haber hecho política el presidente
demuestra una fuerza muy muy grande y
seguramente va a impactar en el proceso
electoral y ya a partir de mañana hará
con que todos sus adversarios los
contrincantes del primer presidente
empiece a revisar las estrategias y eso
por qué porque el principal oponente de
bolsonaro luiz inácio lula da silva
hasta el día de hoy no ha salido ninguna
vez a las calles no ha involucrado se
con la población y es es un diferencial
enorme que va a ser las selecciones del
tren del 2 de octubre
por otro lado bolsonaro ha rechazado las
encuestas que le dan por perdedor eso es
todo un indicio de que tampoco podría
aceptar los resultados si éstos no le
favorecen
no de ninguna forma hay un conciencia
entre sus principales consejeros los
partidos que lo apoyan lo el presidente
de la cámara de diputados por ejemplo
que desde el tercero en la guerra que
política de que los resultados serán
aceptos lo que se está haciendo mucho en
brasil es sembrando un clima de tensión
donde no hay obviamente que el
presidente tiene un histórico de ser un
terreno opositor a los movimientos de
izquierda a los partidos comunistas y
etcétera pero el respecto a las
elecciones pasan muy muy distante de lo
que piensa exactamente el presidente el
país tiene instituciones
extremamente sólidas un proceso
electoral bastante sólido y lo que
bolsonaro hace es
percibirlo y respetarlo obviamente que
en un momento como el que hemos tenido
el día de hoy como te dice que ha
arrastrado a millones de personas a las
calles sorprendiendo incluso los
consejeros de campaña del presidente
seguramente esto va a ser una nueva
marca nueva pero no hay absolutamente
ningún riesgo de que los resultados de
octubre no sean aceptos ahora se
esperaban discursos de bolsonaro que
atacaran al sistema electoral de brasil
como es costumbre pero no fue así a qué
se debe esta aparente reducción de su
retórica contra las instituciones
brasileñas
yo diría que los números son los que se
impone andrés porque si vamos a analizar
lo que está pasando en brasil way como
por ejemplo lo que pasa en el vecindario
en latinoamérica y si comparamos más
allá con eeuu y la mayor parte de europa
brasil y realmente es una isla no
tenemos por ejemplo
difundidos esta semana los números del
desempleo del paro y son los menores
desde el 2015 la economía también va
mejorando la inflación está bajo control
el precio del combustible ha bajado
muchísimo de lo que impacta directamente
en la economía de la gente además
o el auxilio brasil que es un problema
social que nació de lo que fue el bolsa
familia introducido en el gobierno de
fernando henrique cardoso en los 90
luego mantenido por dura da silva en los
principios del año 2000 ahora es un
programa muchísimo más fuerte con un
apoyo financiero muchísimo mayor a toda
la gente y estamos hablando de cerca de
20 millones de familias yo creo que el
presidente ha sido convencido andrés de
que los logros que ha tenido brasil en
la economía sobre todo desde mediados de
julio hasta el momento que estamos es
muchísimo más positivo de ser explotados
en una campaña que simplemente a atacar
digamos o criticar a las instituciones
al supremo tribunal federal y el pro se
apropió el proceso electoral